il est défendu on regarde ensuite
comment va se dérouler le reste de la
séance monsieur le président à bas bruit
à bas bruit
merci merci madame ministre
donc monsieur vallini sur ministre je
sollicite une suspension de séance de 10
minutes
monsieur le président en vient donc on
va suspendre la séance 10 minutes
chers collègues
la séance est reprise madame la ministre
vous avez substitué à un amendement 11
122 un amendement 761 qui a été retiré
pourriez vous le présenter merci
monsieur le président avec une erreur
qui était soulevée par un certain nombre
de sénateurs pendant la suspension de
séance qui souhaitent avec juste raison
ce ne soit pas la politique touristique
de la région mais du conseil régional
effectivement il faut pas que l'on
confond didier on aura souvent
d'ailleurs ce cas quand on parlera aussi
des départements ne pas confondre le
département zones géographiques où
vivent des collectivités territoriales
sans tutelle évidemment et le
département et son conseil départemental
donc après avoir entendu ce que je vous
dis monsieur le président en avant
l'ensemble de beaucoup d'intervenants
nous nous étions je le redis rapidement
la commission a été conduite à faire un
amendement à un article que le
gouvernement a déposé donc nous assumons
l'entière responsabilité du fait que
dans cet article nous avions gardé un
schéma régional alors que nous n'avions
pas choisi cette option pour la culture
et pour le sport qui sont les deux
autres compétences partagées en écoutant
les uns les autres on voit bien que la
crainte jeudi le mans parce qu'il est
entendu ressenti c'est que la région
dans sa façon de conduire son schéma
soit une sorte de tutelle sur les autres
que d'activités territoriales donc quand
on entend cette crainte plein d'autant
que le schéma doit conduire un schéma
non seulement je serai des grandes
options mais des investissements par
exemple la crainte et les là donc moi je
suis sensible avec andré vallini 7 ce
ressenti et on se dit au fond est-ce
qu'il faut passer parce que l'accord
locaux élaboration la co construction
d'un schéma qui comprend les grandes
orientations de ycompris l'image etc
mais les grandes orientations
investissements compris c'est
extrêmement difficile à faire donc ça va
être très complexe de conduire 7
ce travail de de chez marc donc l'idée
que jeu qui nous est maintenant enfin où
nous avons une certitude maintenant
c'est que le mieux est de supprimer le
schéma régional comme pour le sport et
la culture compétences partagées n'ont
pas besoin de schémas ensuite nous
avions une position constante c'est que
quand ya des compétences partagées sport
et culture après de longs débats pendant
la loi map table nous avions convenu que
le chef du file à ne s'impose pas en
revanche là où on voit bien compte tenu
de l'existence des crt par exemple on
voit bien que une concertation peut être
intéressant donc nous avons proposé que
la région reste le chef du file de cette
compétence partagée qui permet
effectivement beaucoup d'avancé
et nous ajoutons parce que c'est une
demande récurrente et justifié la
possibilité pour les crt pour les
régions en tant qu'institution j'entends
puisse naturellement fusionner leurs
outils avec les régions voisines on a
déjà sur une très fin sur deux très
grandes régions cette demande que les
départements s'ils le veulent puissent
fusionner leurs cdt qui ne sont pas
obligatoires je pense que faut qu'on
allège toutes les contraintes qu'en mai
à nos collectivités locales ce qui nous
sépare parce qu'il faut savoir ce qui
nous sépare c'est cette notion de chef
de file à sur une compétence partagée
n'ai pas trouvé mieux que le chef du
file à pour éviter effectivement qui
n'est pas de coordination
merci madame la ministre
donc l'amendement 11 122 a été remplacé
par un amendement en ce sens 22 rectifié
qui vous a été distribué nous passons à
la suite des amendements discussion
commune avec un amendement 849 présentée
par monsieur favier ou madame comptiez
morin madame gauthier - oui je pensais
que ça allait un petit peu redistribuer
les choses ça c'était je joue je vous
proposais de défendre de façon commune
le 849 et le 850 monsieur le président
qui était 2 amendement de repli qui
s'inscrivait dans la suite de refus
donnant un autre amendement de
suppression de l'article iv est en fait
il revenait sur la suppression ou la
modification de rédaction de certaines
idées à de cet article 4 et s'inscrivait
totalement dans notre prévention va les
soucis qu'ils ont pu être émis ici
considérant que
le texte initial celui de la commission
allait faisait un pas dans la direction
de notre souci mais en même temps ne
réglait pas totalement le cas parce que
si effectivement la région n'avaient
plus le titre de chef de file
cette la mission et le mode
d'intervention ne changeait pas aux
fausses quant au fond se fait donc
c'était deux amendement de repli mais je
suppose que tout va être distribué suite
à la proposition du gouvernement
merci nous passons donc aux 1084
amendements au nom de la commission des
lois
monsieur le président merci monsieur le
président je vois bien l'effort qui est
fait par par le gouvernement pour se
rapprocher des positions de la
commission et la commission elle-même
mais prête à faire un effort pour se
rapprocher des positions qui sont
exprimées par le gouvernement avec une
limite pour nous qui est que nous ne
voulons pas accepter cette notion de
chef de file que vous défendez pour la
région cet amendement 1084 a été adoptée
à l'unanimité de la commission
qu'est-ce qu'il dit si je le traduis il
dit premièrement le schéma régional
on en veut bien mais il est facultatif
il est élaboré conjointement par la
région les départements et les
collectivités territoriale à statut
particulier situé sur le territoire de
la région et je propose monsieur le
président sur ce premier point
un sous-amendement il faut dire pour que
ce soient parfaitement claires la région
les départements les collectivités
territoriale à statut particulier
élabore et adoptent c'est ce que
j'ajoute et adopte conjointement
le schéma régional de développement
touristique
ça c'est le premier point il est
facultatif ce schéma puisque il
n'existera qu'après avoir été élaborée
et adoptée par l'ensemble de ces
collectivités
élaborée et adoptée par ces
mais pas sans avoir recueilli l'avis
pendant cette phase préparatoire des
communes et de leurs groupements
compétents sur le territoire de la
région et c'est très important d'ajouter
et c'est le deuxième âge ou que je veux
faire au nom de la commission des lois
les communes et leurs groupements
compétents situé sur le territoire de la
région notamment les stations
touristiques car elles ont l'inquiétude
d'être écartée du processus
en ajoutant cette mention nous apportons
à ses stations touristiques au sens de
la loi
reconnu comme station touristique la
garantie qu'elles seront bien associé à
l'élaboration de ce schéma facultatif
ensuite tout se déroule très simplement
on définit le contenu du schéma mais il
n'a rien qui n'ait été préalablement
consentis par les parties prenantes de
l'élaboration et de l'adoption du schéma
et qui plus est il est prévu que en ce
qui concerne les actions qui vont être
mises en oeuvre elles et c'est le
dernier paragraphe
elles seront mises en oeuvre avec des
conventions nous avons pardonnez-moi la
trivialité de l'expression bretelles et
ceintures les bretelles c'est
l'élaboration et l'adoption conjointe la
ceinture c'est la convention pour
l'application ainsi nous nous retrouvons
avec un dispositif où le schéma
n'existera que quand il apporte quelque
chose qui paraît utile à l'ensemble des
collectivités de la région
sans cela il n'existe pas mais nous
n'avons aucune raison de nous priver de
la possibilité de cette valeur ajoutée
qui pour nos destinations touristiques
peut apporter quelque chose de plus que
la promotion que nous organisons au plus
près
et de ses destinations touristiques et
voilà la raison pour laquelle je
souhaite que cet amendement soit adopté
et se substitue aux autres amendements
qui ont été proposées sur ce point merci
monsieur le président donc si je
comprends bien le 1084 deviendrai un
1084 rectifié qu'ils différaient du 1084
de la manière suivante dans le premier
alinéa du grand 2 on dirait élabore et
adopte conjointement le schéma régional
et dans le deuxième alinéa du grand 2
vous rajoute auriez notamment les
stations touristiques après sur le
territoire de la région
c'est bien cela donc l'amendement
rectifié va vous être distribués nous
passons à l'amendement 408 au nom de la
commission des affaires économiques
monsieur lenoir monsieur le président
bien monsieur le président madame la
ministre mes chers collègues j'ai été
heureux d'entendre la brisant la
commission des lois a argumenté
l'amendement qui a été adopté par sa
commission
à l'évidence la commission affaires
économiques a inspiré la commission des
lois chez la plus grande estime pour les
membres de cette commission
mais c'est vrai que dès la mi décembre
nous avions suggéré cette solution et je
vois que la date à laquelle votre
commission s'est réunie se situe
exactement un mois plus tard et bien
vous avez eu le temps de prendre
connaissance de nos arguments alors nous
sommes pratiquement sur la même ligne et
les quelques précisions vous avez
apporté monsieur le président me
permettent de dire que nous devrions
déboucher sur un accord néanmoins je
relève
je relève une petite différence c'est
que l'exercice conjoint auquel la
commission des affaires économiques
songé associer l'ensemble des
collectivités
du reste je note que dans l'objet de
votre amendement il est dit le présent
amendement vise à renforcer le caractère
conjointe de l'élaboration du schéma
régional de lento ristic par la région
les départements les métropoles les
communes et leurs groupements
c'est pas exactement ce que dit votre
amendement
car il y à une élaboration conjointe au
niveau de la région des départements et
collectivités territoriales à cette
pratique eu lieu mais les communes et
leurs groupements sont associés à
l'élaboration et une nuance importante
nous nous avions envisagé que l'ensemble
de ces collectivités territoriales et de
leurs groupements puisse participer à
cette élaboration moi je m'en tiens à
cette version de l'amendement qui a été
adopté par la commission à vrdnik je
crois à l'unanimité sur un second point
et là vous aviez tout à fait raison de
souligner que la convention
le schéma tient lieu de convention
territoriale exercice exactement le
processus que nous avions envisagé donc
je vois monsieur le président que un
effort doit être fait je n'étais pas
encore parti mais nous devrions trouver
rapidement un accord
merci monsieur le président le 850 a été
présenté par madame gonthier-maurin donc
nous passons à cinq amendements en
discussion commune
le 34 rectifié bis n'est pas soutenu le
64 rectifié debise c'est monsieur
detraigne chez le président un lait les
amendements là qui vont se suivre et qui
sont identiques donne l'impression qu'il
s'agit d'une question de vocabulaire on
dit qu'il faut remplacer le mot le
expression schéma régional de
développement touristique par schéma de
développement des destinations
touristiques en réalité il s'agit de
faire coller les
les schémas au terrain le lia dans une
même région
il y à de nombreuses destinations
touristiques et on a des visiteurs qui
viennent pour des destinations variées
donc il s'agit s'il ya des destinations
qui évidemment sont sont très fortes
quand on parle de paris d'ile-de-france
etc
il y à des destinations en france qui
sont beaucoup moins moins forte et qu'il
convient d'intégrer dans les
dans ce schéma territorial donc c'est
l'objet c'est de sa part et comme une
question de vocabulaire mais qui n'est
pas qu'ils ne manquent pas de deux sens
il faut développer des destinations
touristiques et pas et pas seulement des
veut développer déjà et dire des
destinations générique pas seulement un
schéma générique main schéma pour les
destinations touristiques qui sont très
variés si monsieur de tringle e75 n'est
pas défendu pas plus que le 386 et nous
en arrivons aux 669 monsieur eblé vous
avez la parole oui monsieur le président
nos ministres mes chers collègues sur
les mêmes bases qui vient d'être révoqué
je propose le remplacement du terme
régional de développement touristique
par développement des destinations
touristiques
ceux-ci introduirait pour la première
fois au plan local l'échelle
d'intervention pertinente des politiques
publiques touristiques que sont les
destinations touristiques nous avons eu
beaucoup de discussions de savoir
quelles étaient les collectivités
pertinentes à agir et comment elles
devaient articuler leurs propres
responsabilités
je pense qu'une partie de la réponse se
situe dans la valorisation de ces
destinations qui sont de taille fort
diverses et
qu'ils s'adressent à des clientèles
touristiques à des échelons différents
il y à des destinations qui ont vocation
à se structurer au plan international
d'autres au plan simplement européens
voire même national ou local
il est donc proposé d'établir un cadre
cohérent autour de ces destinations
entre les actions de l'état puisque
l'état s'est d'ores et déjà engagé
autour de cette échelle et les
collectivités territoriales l'état et
les professionnels du tourisme ont déjà
tous intégrés l'échelle des destinations
touristiques les collectivités locales
doivent désormais le faire également
si monsieur eblé monsieur bouvard vous
avez la parole pour le 802 oui je vais
pouvoir être plus plus brefs ans pour
remerciant le gouvernement et la
commission de la qualité du dialogue
qu'on a pu avoir pendant la suspension
donc cet amendement était évidemment
dans la version du texte avant les
modifications et avait pour but de
sortir du schéma les investissements et
l'aménagement en effet il apparaît que
ce qui est important dans un schéma
c'est les actions de promotion
d'organisation des filières qui sont les
endroits où on peut légitimement faire
des économies d'échelle et gagner en
efficacité
dès lors que la position de la région
primait dans la rédaction initiale du
texte
il n'était pas pensable que le schéma
puissent définir les investissements et
les aménagements et que la liberté
prévue par la compétence partagée des
autres collectivités se trouve encadré
puisque j indique qu'au delà du dur au
delà de 2 c du 5
quand on aller un peu plus loin dans le
texte et qu'on tombait sur l'article l
132 1
on nous disait dans chaque département
le conseil général est chargé sur son
territoire d'assurer la mise en oeuvre
opérationnelle des orientations définies
par le schéma régional
voilà pour ces débats dans l'hémicycle
sur le projet de loi notre nouvelle
organisation territoriale de la
république qui définit l'art
partitions des compétences entre les
différentes collectivités
ce matin les sénateurs examinent et plus
particulièrement les compétences des
régions en matière de tourisme
un débat vous l'avez vu assez
respectueux assez feutrée
compte tenu des évènements de la semaine
dernière et bien pas question de faire
preuve d'agressivité dans l'hémicycle
vous pouvez toujours voir et revoir
toutes les séances sur notre site
publicsenat.fr
très bonne journée à tous sur les
chaînes parlementaires